bonjour à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
au programme de cette édition la ferme
de bel ébat propose le 12 octobre une
journée entière de spectacles consacrés
aux clowns et plus précisément au clown
féminin
yoann la babre directeur et
programmateur vous donne tous les
détails philosophie et musique
un métissage est au nom au micro de
nicolas jaar vais l'ensemble archi
musique raconte ce défi d'interprétation
michel boujenah sur scène à la salle
jacques-brel nous présente son one man
show ma vie aux turbines auto biographie
imaginaire
chaque semaine septième art est mise à
l'honneur dans notre chronique
cinéphiles bertrand pigné responsable du
cinéma les yeux des izards sens hier
l'école nous livre son coup de coeur
parmi les nouveautés de la saison
2013-2014 la ferme de bel ébat à
guyancourt propose quatre journées sur
une thématique particulière
ce samedi 12 octobre il s'agira d'une
journée consacrée au cirque ivanova
bonsoir vous êtes donc le directeur de
la ferme de bel ébat bonsoir alors vous
allez nous raconter cette journée
comment comment va-t-elle se comment ça
va se dérouler il y aura il y aura donc
cinq spectacles tout au long de la
journée
et l'idée c'était de faire grandir le
spectateur au fil des heures pour des
temps de partage en famille donc à 11
heures on aura un premier spectacle à
partir de 3 ans ensuite à 14 heures ce
sera un spectacle à partir de 4 ans à 16
heures ce sera à partir de 8 ans puis à
18h à partir de 10 ans et enfin à 21h un
spectacle pour les un petit peu plus
grand à partir d'une douzaine d'années
voilà pour les ados et les adultes eux
puis d'accord alors la particularité
aussi de cette journée cirque c'est que
ce sont les clowns qui sont mis à
l'honneur mais plus précisément les
clowns féminin alors j'ai envie de vous
demander pourquoi une programmation que
de femmes la ferme de bel ébat comme il
savait est engagée dans dans ce
processus de valorisation de la création
fait main
afin de lutter contre ' le peu de place
qui est faite aux femmes dans le monde
de la création contrairement à beaucoup
d'idées reçues
alors ensuite c'est vrai que le clown
c'est une figure un petit peu étrange on
va dire c'est une figure asexuée c'est
un petit peu comme l'ange les ans les
anges n'ont pas de sexe les clowns a
priori non plus pourtant on imagine
souvent le clou nous sommes d'ailleurs
on dit bien un crime c'est ainsi d'un
mot masculin et quand s'approche du
clown de théâtre qui est un clown assez
spécifique quand même c'est pas le cloud
sous chapiteau mais le clown qui arpente
les scènes de théâtre et bien souvent ce
sont des femmes
je vois que quand je pense au clown de
théâtre je pense qu'un des femmes je
pense à arletty je pense à emma la clown
qu'on retrouve au prisme cette saison
aussi également à lucie wallon adèll
nodé langlois qu'on reçoit
voilà ce sont évidemment madame
françoise aussi des nouveaux nés qui est
une des figures importantes du clown et
du renouveau du genre
donc je pense que les femmes ont apporté
beaucoup au clown est donc assez
naturellement cette journée s'est
consacré aux clowns féminin d'accord
alors le premier spectacle
le premier spectacle qui s'appelle
antiste donc il s'adresse aux plus
jeunes
oui alors comment qu'est ce qui va se
passer dans ce spectacle alors en piste
c'est un petit cirque miniature et
grenadines la clown donc va faire un
cirque de bric et de broc tous les
numéros qu'elle peut pas faire tout seul
puisque voilà elle monte un petit
chapiteau elle tend un petit fils voilà
et alors on va assister à tous les
numéros du cirque traditionnel
jusqu aux acrobates qui sera un joli
numéro de pop corn qui sautent ils font
des saltos à 14h c'est plume et paille
alors un duo de clowns qui sutil alors
on a deux clowns bien différent dans
plume et paille
on a une clown danseuse et chanteuse et
une clown harpiste et donc elle nous
livre une fantaisie burlesque et
bucolique très légère très belle voilà
qui permet aussi d'approcher d'approcher
la musique pour les
jeunes oui absolument écoutez je vous
propose qu'on regarde un extrait de ces
deux spectacles à l'univers féerique et
bucolique
non
et
dans votre programmation vous présentez
également une création création par le
théâtre de chair nous qui étale la
verrière il s'agit de la classe envolés
c'est un an de quoi s'agit-il
oui c'est celle est la première partie
du nouveau projet de grégoire cuvier
donc c'est un diptyque est là la classe
envolées donc c'est l'histoire de mal à
quai malaquais est un être imaginaire
qui va dans une salle de classe
désaffecté qui a dû être évacuée et qui
va chercher le doudouk eu qu'une petite
fille alia oubliée voilà on est dans un
univers à la fois très poétique et plein
plein de sens voilà ce jeu c'est une
création donc je ne les ai pas vus ce
serait me sera la première c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous n'avons pas
d'extrait pour ce spectacle là alors on
va quitter l'imaginaire pour partir vers
un monde un petit peu plus empreint de
réalité celui d'annabelle c'est le clown
d'hôpital en fait avec la pièce merci
d'être venu donc qui sera 18 heures
récit oui absolument donc à 18h sandra
meunier son nom de scène annabelle qui
est une étoile dit elle va mais comme un
nez voilà comme le nez rouge wall and
étoiles et annabelle raconte son
parcours en hôpital notamment en soins
palliatifs où elle vient distiller un
peu d'amour un peu de vie dans des
endroits où ils seront en spectacle mais
également pour de vrai absolument elle
le fait pour de vrai et le spectacle
raconte cette expérience là sandra
travail à trappes avec une association
qui s'appelle le pallium qui donc
s'occupe de ce rapace il ya tiff à
domicile et elle travaille également
c'est un sujet douloureux avec des
enfants endeuillés et elle fait une fois
par mois un atelier avec le pallium pour
des enfants endeuillés
le spectacle sera suivi d'une discussion
d'une rencontre publique avec sandra qui
parlera de cette expérience très riche
très riche
effectivement alors est le cinquième et
dernier spectacle qui est présenté à 21h
on pour les un petit peu plus
les plus grands on va dire les ados à
peu près donc là il s'agit d' antigone à
l'anti qu on connaît bien au théâtre est
là c'est une version clownesque dans un
univers un peu tragique
comment ça va se passer absolument c'est
un spectacle d'adèle nodé langlois qui
est une figure montante du clown
aujourd'hui et vous savez souvent on dit
les extrêmes se rejoignent et le
spectacle le montre bien comment
finalement la figure tragique et la
figure comique arrive à ce synthétiser
donc elle va nous raconter l'histoire
d'antigone la vraie histoire d'un team n
mais avec ce regard décalé du clown
d'accord bah écoutez ça va merci
beaucoup de nous avoir présenté toute
cette programmation
donc on rappelle la date c'est le 12
octobre de 11h jusqu'à 21h vous avez et
si tous les renseignements pour réserver
merci beaucoup d'être venu sur le
plateau d'i kiosque
merci à vous nous continuons et nous
allons retrouver tout de suite nicolas
gervais
nicolas cette semaine nous fait
découvrir le rêve de nietzsche donc il
s'agit d'une d'une étonnante
un étonnant métissage en fait entre eux
la philosophie et la musique s'est
d'ailleurs présenté à la ferme de bel
ébat le 15 ans les quotas il a d'abord
créé ce spectacle avec rocé en y mettant
son immense soif de métissage musical
on y entend les mots de nietzsche scandé
pas le rappeur j me justine j'aurais mig
et dont nous parle du rêve de nietzsche
un spectacle qui sera présenté notamment
le 15 octobre à la ferme de bel bat à
cuire nous sommes donc jamais plaint
d'être mais comprimé connu plus poteau
de calomnier malentendu ai pas entendu
tout près des précisément notre sort mme
sow pour être modèle jusqu'en 1900
invités aussi ce qui nous honorent ou 3
30 au tap est tout de même chanson croix
sont continuellement aux jetons
confiance des corses plus en achat
comptant le souhaitent de venir vous
gêne vous à venir plus haut plus fort
encore aujourd'hui tous heureusement nos
racines dans les profondeurs dans le var
non seulement il fait de la musique mais
ils improvisent il ya une scène avec
richard wagner excusez du peu
ils discutent cosima à la fin de wagner
richard wagner réduit ils disent que
deux philosophies sa part dans l'est
dans les hautes sphères et d'émotion il
se jette au piano de du maître de wagner
effet une improvisation pendant cinq
minutes il s'arrête et richard et sa
femme
bravo superbe donc moi un type comme ça
j'ai regardé il ya peu de jazzman qu'on
fait des trucs autour de lui
e
mon année ce sera triste de l'époque qui
m'a dit tiens il ya un rappeur rocé qui
est super branché nietzsche je dis allez
allons voir et puis on a fait la
création avec rocé il ya deux ans 2011
au tamanoir à gennevilliers et qu'on a
repris à banlieues bleues deux jours
après et puis rossé pareil planning très
chargé me dit très gentiment là pendant
deux ans je veux pas me permettre de ces
tragédies écoute je peux pas laisser
dormir ce projet et du coup j'ai branché
quelqu'un que j'ai rencontrés lors de
lors d'ateliers
un jeune rappeur qui s'appelle jimmy
justin jimmy vous le verrez à la ferme
de bel ébat il est absolument captivant
il est incroyablement captivante nous
aussi nous fréquentons des sommes nous
aussi nous en fut londres d'est mans le
costume selon lesquelles nous connaît
considère recherche pour lequel on nous
prend et vêtus de la sorte nous nous
rendons société c'est-à-dire par
qui ne veut pas j'ai une envie de faire
coexister musique et mots et surtout
c'est suivre ce personnage ce nietzsche
qui ne comprend pas dans sa vie pourquoi
sa musique n'est pas reçu de la même
façon que sa philosophie dire que tout
fondateur un tour âges tous ses pôles tu
dises laisse tomber la musique des idées
sont formidables fons là dedans mais
oublie la musique et lui ne comprend pas
et il c'est un personnage qui a
tellement d'urgence que ça sort de sa
tête donc tous à s'asseoir de sa tête ça
jaillit comme un volcan et donc ça à
droite cité pourquoi la philosophie est
pas la musique c'est moi donc c'est dû
demander de se séparer
et donc si j'ai appelé ce projet moi le
rêve de nietzsche c'est que c'est que ce
qu'il a ce qui était son rêve c'est de
voir sa musique et sa fessée idée
jaillir et à égalité on va dire j'ai
essayé très immodestement c'est
n'importe quoi
mais jessica st dié et puis vous verrez
de faire coexister mots et musique et je
pense que ça fonctionne ou aussi le
faisons comme tous ces masques avisé
émettons poliment à la porte toute
curiosité
porto passé
costumes
nous aussi
le principe de l'ensemble archives
musées que l'ensemble qui présida à ce
concert c'est de mélanger et écriture et
improvisation le ce qu'on a fait comme
travail par rapport aux mots ça a été un
choix de textes avec rocé au départ et
on a répété ensemble en fait avec la
rythmique
il y avait là la contrebasse la batterie
rossé et moi et puis on tâtonnait un peu
ensemble ça a été assez collectif la
façon de de deux mois j'ai amené un
matériel rythmique rossé il a calé des
textes et puis après à partir de ces cas
là j'ai un peu j'ai réécrit pour pour le
reste de l'orchestré et djiby après en
second temps à garder des choses que
rossi avait avait avait mis c'est à dire
qu'il s'est mis dans les chais dans
l'est dans les clous dans les chaussons
de rosser et puis amené des choses à lui
alors qu'il a greffé sur la musique déjà
existantes
j'ai tourné dos gouvernants lorsque je
vis ce qu'il nomme à présent gouverner
trafic et marchandages de pouvoir avec
la canal
et
ces quatre musiciens issus du classique
et jazz man on a 20 ans cette année et
on est les seuls à avoir fait ce
métissage dans la durée un ensemble qui
se constitue avec ses deux familles on
va dire on est les seuls je pense
e
j'ai envie de dire aux gens qui vont
venir au concert c'est comme si vous
veniez dans un restaurant non vous ne
connaîtriez pas le menu mais dont vous
savez que vous allez apprécier la
nourriture je m'y engage
parce que j'ai l'habitude depuis vingt
ans et on a une offre une nourriture
artistique riche qui fait que même si
pendant trois quatre minutes au début on
se demande un petit peu mais qu'est ce
qu'ils font parce que c'est un peu
singulier on trouve de quoi manger et
les gens ne partent jamais nos concerts
et voilà le rêve de nietzsche c'est donc
le 15 octobre à la ferme de bel ébat a
accueilli en cours et la hora ya je
crois qu'on peut dire que c'est la bande
de base
non merci nicolas on retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour de nouvelles découvertes
alors nous avons rencontré hier soir à
la salle jacques brel à michel boujenah
qui était présent pour son spectacle ma
vie auto biographie imaginaire la
rencontre avec un homme pudique mais qui
manie rire et émotion chez elle bouge
l'avant soir bons soins on vous retrouve
donc ce soir à la salle jacques brel à
montigny vous présentez votre one man
show ma vie une autobiographie
imaginaire car c'est vrai qu'à l'heure
où le public est plutôt friand des
téléréalités
d'une vie un peu cachée des stars on a
envie de connaître leur vie réelle en
fait vous vous présentez une vie
imaginaire pourquoi parce que parce que
ma vie à moi au premier degré elle a
aucun intérêt et que c'est que ce
spectacle c'est c'est plus une réflexion
sur la vie que ma vie à moi
alors évidemment dedans il ya des des
histoires qui me touche de près c'est en
train de quelques réalités je dirais pas
quoi mais c'est très imaginaire c'est
plus beau de rêver sa vie que de la
vivre donc les besoins quels thèmes vous
aborder tout au long de ce spectacle
ben l'enfance l'exil
bizarrement la mort la nostalgie la
tunisie oui un peu la tunisie on est au
début surtout
lahlimi relation amoureuse à
l'adolescence avec les filles évidemment
tout ça est très drôle enfin en principe
drôles ou touchants mais moi je peux pas
là assis dans un fauteuil ça mange c'est
un peu inquiète je suis incapable de
deux de vous faire rire comme ça donc on
va rire de ma capacité à tourner en
dérision tout par exemple quand un gamin
de 10 ans à 4 heures du matin réveil ses
parents en leur disant à quoi ça sert de
vivre s'il ya la face pour mourir
pourquoi la vie était fait mais pourquoi
la vie est éphémère et la mort éternelle
et le père lui dit mais à 4 heures du
matin tu veux savoir ça tu veux pas
tomber lutter tu vois et quand il dit
mais pourquoi on dit mourir de plaisir
pourquoi la mort c'est un plaisir
pourquoi on dit mourir de joie ce que
l'amorcé si je voyais que ça et et
aperam en 2010 par exemple ici mais je
n'en peux plus
je meurs de sommeil et il le dit toi tu
dis pourquoi heures de sommeil c'est il
ya à la fois des choses comme ça très
fine sur un enfant qui se posent des
questions toutes simples sur la vie il
ya des choses beaucoup plus délirantes
c'est qui qui à partir des cauchemars ce
que dernier cauchemar qu'elle a fait
s'est réveillée elle était dans la peau
de françois hollande c'est compliqué
surtout en ce moment pour dans la vie
fut très pudique y compris alors que je
le suis un peu moins d'un spectacle mais
on va on va rire on va être touchée de
d'une mère qui dit enfin la vérité
puisque elle dit que en gros que les
maires finalement
le rôle qu'on leur a donné le rôle
qu'elles ont assumé c'est d'être
inquiète et de nourrir leurs enfants
c'est à dire en fait moi j'avais pas
envie de ça du tout en fait j'étais pas
inquiète mais si j'avais pas été
inquiète
on aurait dit que j'étais une mauvaise
mère mon fils m'a dit moi je vais faire
un test de maternité au bout de 35 ans
de travail seul sur scène je suis
toujours incapable avec mon travail je
suis toujours
ouais jeux panam d'interviews chpa
nombre de télévisions je suis pas un
homme de tout ça je suis juste un garçon
qui aime raconter des histoires sur
scène et quels ont été les premiers
retours alors de cette première date à
c'était bien mais quand on n'est pas
content tu espères c'était samedi on est
super content on va bien voir comment ce
petit bébé va va continuer à évoluer
oui total en deux sets tornay bien sûr
bien sûr tout le temps tout le temps
mais tout le temps même quand je vais
faire pareil ligne il évolue tous les
jours tous les jours tous les jours il
arrive un petit truc ou un gros truc
vous changez vos rêves c'est une
écriture qui est vivant qui vues
séparément
je suis pas mort comme auteur encore
donc je peux encore écrire y compris
quand je joue c'est sûr merci beaucoup
monsieur je vous en prie merci passons
tout huet à notre chronique cinéphiles
nous sommes mercredi c'est donc l'heure
des sorties ciné au micro elodie moines
c'était très distrayant et j'ai passé un
très bon moment
les acteurs
principaux en fait sont des acteurs que
j'apprécie particulièrement
j'ai vraiment passé un très bon moment
on sait d'avancé ce qui va se passer
et ben on se sent plus quoi j'ai une
bonne détente
c'est une bonne entente il joue très
bien
il est très belle image maintenant c'est
plaisant c'est un gros film s'appelle
des souvenirs parce que les vues
peut-être une trentaine d'années donc là
en 3d c'est pas mal les enfants bien
mais aussi j'aimais bien c'était bien et
chanter
g j'ai vu qu'ils se baladaient bien et
c'était le film était très bien la
chronique cinéphiles c'est aussi
l'occasion d'entendre un professionnel
du cinéma nous donner son coup de coeur
de la semaine
eh bien là c'est au tour de bertrand
pigné responsable et du cinéma les yeux
d'elsa à saint-cyr-l'ecole le coup de
coeur au cinéma les yeux d'elsa cette
semaine c'est le film de avi mograbi
dans un jardin je suis entré
c'est un documentaire israélien réalisé
par avi mograbi s'est questionné le
spectateur mais il va aussi questionné
lui en tant que réalisateur dont se
montrent très compliqué que le monde
israël aux palestiniens
le film se construit autour de la
préparation d'un film lors duquel admis
au grade i fait appel à son ami ali un
palestinien qui parle et maîtrise donc
mieux l'arabe que lui pour préparer le
film traduire des choses retrouver des
images des photographies d'époque etc
et petit à petit en fait c'est un autre
film qui va se construire un film dans
lequel avis et ali vont se réinterroger
e sur israël la palestine leur place à
eux par rapport à tout ça et
et ça fout du coup très émouvant parce
que très personnel pour le réalisateur
qui souvent face caméra qui interpelle
souvent le spectateur
pour ce deuxième personnage qui se
retrouvent à devenir un personnage de
cinéma alors qu'il n'a pas vocation à
l'être s'est plaint de tout petits
moments comme ça qui sont des hasards du
réel puisqu'on est dans le temps dans le
cinéma documentaire qui sont des
bouffées d'émotion parce que le réel
tout à coup rattrape l'écriture
cinématographique qui vont à four al
youm unit est fort et là je vous propose
à présent quelques idées de sorties
c'est prochains jours alors tout d'abord
rendez vous annuel de la nuit blanche à
saint quentin en yvelines ce sera samedi
5 octobre à partir de 17 heures au
quartier 17 mar à elancourt un programme
riche et varié performance de l'artiste
plasticien emmanuel bâillon rencontres
d'auteurs lecture de contes à la
librairie une flash mob projection au
cinéma le ciné 7 et enfin un concert
d'oxmo puccino au prisme deuxième
rendez-vous s'il s'agit toujours dans le
cadre donc des nuits blanches mais cette
fois ci à versailles et se tiendra la
nuit de la création donc c'est une
découverte pour le public
d'installations artistiques visibles
dans différents quartiers quartier ce
sera donc samedi à partir de 20 heures
et enfin pour les amateurs de musique
classique et noté que les journées ravel
se tiendront à montfort l'amaury du 5 au
13 octobre
voilà notre édition est à présent
terminé merci de nous avoir suivi sur
téléphiles je vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine en direct à 18h 30 25